[Music]
nihilism comes from the latin word naijo
which means nothing it is a word
associated with meaninglessness
rejection of values and giving up on
life nihilism doesn't sound like a very
positive word and for some reason
nietzsche's name is strongly connected
with it but was nietzsche really a
nihilist and if he was what did he
really mean by nihilism let's try and
find out
the german philosopher friedrich
heinrich jacoby was one of the first to
use the term nihilism in philosophical
writings towards the end of the 18th
century later on in russia nihilism
became synonymous with a revolutionary
movement that rejected the authority of
the state church and the traditional
values of the time russian anarchist
peter krotoptkin as stated in the
encyclopedia britannica defined nihilism
as the symbol of struggle against all
forms of tyranny hypocrisy and
artificiality and for individual freedom
nihilism was essentially the fundamental
value of the anarchist movement that
wanted to destroy the core aspects of
the old world in order to allow a new
one to rise as it is stated in wikipedia
russian nihilism focused on those things
that it saw as meaningless in the
dominant hegemony of religion morality
philosophy aesthetics and social
institutions it did however incorporate
theories of hard determinism atheism
materialism positivism and rational
egoism the movement advocated a new
social contract based on materialism and
individual freedom he didn't want people
to rely on religion and abstract
concepts to define their worldview and
social systems at this point i want to
take a moment to explain what
materialism means for those not familiar
with the term a materialist believes
that matter is the fundamental element
of reality in the history of existence
first we had matter incapable of thought
out of which developed thinking matter
aka humans our thoughts do not appear
until we already have matter organized
in a certain manner the human organism
is matter organized in a very
sophisticated way so because of the
historical existence of matter before
the thinking human our mind is just
matter that operates in a specific
manner the reason materialists are so
adamant about this is because they want
to emphasize on what is this worldly and
abstain from many metaphysical
explanations of the world around us
nietzsche was a materialist and that's
probably why nihilism interested him so
much the ideas put forth by the russian
anarchists
reminds a lot of nietzsche's teachings
and most probably nietzsche himself was
influenced by the ideology since it was
popularized around the end of the 19th
century around the time nietzsche
finished his most important works he
mentions nihilism mainly in the notes
that were posthumously published as a
book titled will to power in one note he
writes a nihilist is a man who judges of
the world as it is that it ought not to
be and of the world as it ought to be
that it does not exist
according to this view our existence
action suffering willing feeling has no
meaning
the pathos of in vain is the nihilist's
pathos at the same time as pathos an
inconsistency on the part of the
nihilists it is clear that even in his
notes he does not diverge from his usual
poetic and polemical style what does
nihilism mean that the highest values
devaluate themselves nietzsche likes to
question the nature of things especially
when it comes to values he wants us to
rethink the values that we hold true and
work on the idea of transvaluation of
values since values and ideas that were
considered the ultimate truth at one
point in time don't necessarily need to
stay that way forever when nietzsche
talks about values he mainly means moral
values and religious values he knows
that we see the world through
value-colored eyes and morality and
religion define the color of our world
from the perspective of a nihilist it's
not a question of giving up all values
it's a question of which values we need
to trans value in order to make our
experience in this world more real and
less fictitious as he writes we have
measured the worth of the world
according to the categories which can
only be applied to a purely fictitious
world a nihilist is more of a skeptic
than a cynic the two terms are often
conflicted and conflated but they
constitute two completely different
attitudes towards life nietzsche is
clearly a skeptic he considers
skepticism as something healthy and
cynicism as something unhealthy he
enjoys living with a trial and error
approach he likes to experiment and most
of his writings are an experiment in
revolutionary thinking motifs he wants
to trigger us so we can look deeply
behind things or under things this is
skepticism and it is a sign of mental
health on the other hand cynicism is
about giving up it is about being so
skeptical that you deny almost
everything when you are a cynic you
prefer to shut things down instead of
investigating them deeply nihilism is
closer to skepticism than it is through
cynicism that's why he was so fond of
the term as he writes concerning the
genesis of the nihilist the courage of
all one really knows comes but late in
life it is only quite recently that i
have acknowledged to myself that
heretofore i have been a nihilist from
top to toe the energy and thoroughness
with which i marched forward as a
nihilist deceived me concerning this
fundamental principle when one is
progressing towards a goal it seems
impossible that aimlessness should be
once fundamental article of faith the
great german philosopher martin
heidegger also brooded a lot over the
subject of nihilism as he writes first
nihilism as nietzsche thinks it is the
history of the devaluation of the
highest values hitherto as the
transition to the revaluation of all
prior values as an evaluation that comes
to pass in the discovery of a principle
for a new valuation a principle
nietzsche recognizes as the will to
power heidegger was a hardcore
nietzschean thinker for heidegger
nietzsche is especially important
because he is the manifestation of a
constitutive
sense of the end of western philosophy
but also the man who suggested a way
forward through his ideas about nihilism
and the ubermensch heidegger was deeply
concerned with the growing sense of
emptiness befalling people who decided
to reject traditional religious values
but also couldn't find alternatives his
most popular idea was design which
literally translates to being there
heidegger used the term to shift the
focus on being and being involved with
the world which one inhabits while
remaining aware of this involvement this
idea was quite revolutionary since the
notion of being was usually neglected in
favor of abstract ideas and social myths
people didn't take the time to concern
themselves with a deep exploration of
their inner world their outer world and
their relation to each other in a sense
design was his antidote to nihilism in
closing i want to point out that
nihilism the way we use it today has
nothing to do with the way nietzsche
used it nihilism is not a belief in
nothingness nihilism is the realization
that we shouldn't rely on outdated
belief systems and social myths that
don't really serve our evolution as
nietzsche writes in their will to power
inevitably nihilism will expose all
serious beliefs and sacrosanct truths as
symptoms of defective western mythos
this collapse of meaning relevance and
purpose will be the most destructive
force in history constituting a total
assault on reality and nothing less than
the greatest crisis of humanity what i
relate is the history of the next two
centuries i describe what is coming what
can no longer come differently the
advent of nihilism for some time now our
whole european culture has been moving
us toward the catastrophe with a
tortured tension that is growing from
decade to decade restlessly
violently headlong like a river that
wants to reach the end
nihilism is a warning to ourselves it is
a warning that we should work on this
tension and not just ignore it because
ignoring it can have catastrophic
consequences for everyone
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon adrian out